Voiceover: I have a set of questions
here from school leadership briefing.
The first question is, "The Khan Academy
uses a unique system of teaching,
"where most of the taking in of
information, concrete learning,
"occurs outside the classroom.
And inside the classroom,
"time is spent solving
problems in other pursuits.
"Can you briefly explain how this works?"
So, on a very high level
this is exactly right.
We believe, or the overarching idea here,
is that when people
are in a room together,
students with each other
and students with teachers,
we think the best use of that
time and that scarce time,
is for them to interact with
each other as much as possible.
Leverage the fact that you
have other humans in the room.
We want that time to be spent with
the students teaching each other,
the teachers doing much smaller
group interactions with the students.
As opposed to a traditional kind
of lecture for all of the students,
at the same pace.
And doing things that
there's often not time for.
In a traditional classroom there's
a lot of time spent on lecture.
We like to see teachers
doing more projects,
doing more peer to peer tutoring,
leading to deeper simulations,
and types of experiments.
In terms of how it works,
the simple answer is,
the details we're still learning
what the best way to do it is.
We've done pilots and even in the
pilots that we've been running,
every teacher does it a
different way and we're trying,
to share best practices.
The general idea is, exactly
as this question phrased,
students spent a good amount of
their time so I guess their homework,
is they're watching videos and they're
doing exercises at their own pace.
So they are doing exercises as well.
The teacher gets data on it.
They get a dashboard on it.
They know when and where and what
the students have been working on.
They also get flagged on
what students are stuck on.
When students go into the
classroom they are able,
to continue working at their own
pace on the exercise and the videos.
For maybe 15 to 20 minutes of class time.
While that's occurring, since all the
students are working at their own pace,
the teacher can look at
the dashboard and say,
"Hey look. Billy is stuck
on negative numbers.
"Let me get Susie who's already
mastered that concept to help Billy.
"Or let me go sit next to Billy and see
if I can tutor him on negative numbers."
Or maybe it's something different
because the teacher will also see,
in his or her dashboard that hey
look, Billy has been working,
on Khan Academy at 2 in the morning
maybe he's just not sleeping right.
Maybe something else is going on at home.
To do that very, kind of,
close human interaction,
I think is the most valuable
thing we've been seeing.
The rest of class time, outside
of that Khan Academy experience,
where the students are working with
each other and teaching with each other,
we like to see teachers do as many
projects as they can and simulations.
One thing that we hope to add to Khan
Academy is to actually tell teachers,
"Look these 5 students have
mastered these 5 concepts,
"or these 20 concepts. We think
here's a good example of a project,
"that will stimulate them. That
will let them learn that concept,
"even a little bit deeper."
Other things we've been seeing in classes.
We've seen almost automatic
self-organization take place,
with the students where students
start writing on a wipe board,
what problems or what concepts
they're having trouble with,
and other students are saying what
concepts they're comfortable teaching.
Then they start to kind of
sort it out between them.
With that said, we've been
doing it at Los Altos,
which is an upper middle class to
affluent public school district.
Although one of the classes that
we've been doing a pilot with,
is for their algebra readiness course.
Which is less affluent students,
many English as a second language,
who are having trouble in mathematics.
The results have been
really tremendous there.
We're also doing pilots in East Palo
Alto which is an underserved community.
We're doing one at a charter
school in Redwood City.
We're talking to some other
pretty prominent charter networks,
of experiments with them.
Also in Oakland and in other places.
In all of these pilots,
our goal isn't to say,
"This is how you use Khan Academy, go
use it and let's see what happens."
Our goal is to say we want to
collaborate with these teachers.
The main reason we want to do these
pilots is because we want to explore,
what is the best way to use this tool?
How can we best make class time as
rich of an experience as possible?
And how can we, with the
teachers, the physical experience,
and the Khan Academy experience make
the overall learning experience,
as deep and as long lasting as possible?
Question number two.
"You often talk about using
technology to humanize the classroom.
"How can it do that? How do
you build community around,
"the use of technology in
a classroom or school?"
This kind of goes right
off of the first answer.
I think the mistake with technology
in the classroom in the past is that,
they've been using technology,
frankly, to dehumanize the classroom.
Before, in a traditional classroom
where there's no computer,
you have at least some interaction.
The teacher might lecture for some
time but you do have some opportunity,
to ask the teacher a question or
you might have some opportunity,
to work on some projects together.
Then when you introduce
the computer in that,
where students are spending all of
class time working on computers,
by themselves then all of
a sudden you crowd out,
whatever interaction was there before.
So you're dehumanizing it.
We're seeing it do the opposite.
Let's take to computer,
let's use the computer,
so that the teacher no longer has to
give that one pace fits all lecture.
So that kids don't have to sit
passively for an hour in math class,
or whatever class.
We're going to have physics content.
Physics, chemistry,
biology, and other topics.
When you have every student
working at their own pace,
one it's catering to them so
that's one level of humanity.
Then also, since you freed
up all of this class time,
and you have students
interacting with each other,
and actually interacting with
the teacher in a deeper way,
that's kind of the second order
of humanizing the classroom.
When some people think about
something like Khan Academy,
the knee-jerk reaction is, "Well
how can someone ask a question?
"These are videos. You can't
ask a question on a video."
What we say is that they're exactly right.
We also think that's true
of a lot of lectures.
If you're in a room of 30 kids,
some kids might have the guts,
to raise their hand and ask a question.
It's still not even clear
if that's a good thing,
because it might not be appropriate
question for all of the students.
It might be a question
that's better served offline.
We think a lot of students
aren't asking questions,
in the current form factor.
Maybe just because they're a little lost,
they're not even engaged
in the content enough,
that they can even think of questions.
What we say is, let the kids
do exercises, watch videos,
at their own time, at their own pace.
Let them watch the same video 30
times if that's what it takes.
We've seen examples of that is
what students sometimes need,
to really understand something.
Let the teacher have as much
information as they need,
to make really powerful
judgements about what's going on,
in a student's mind.
Then free up not just a
small fraction of class time,
to ask a teacher question.
Free up all of class time.
So all of class time is
nothing but interactions.
And nothing but questions.
In terms of how do you
build a community around,
the use of technology in
a classroom or school?
Once again, what we're doing in
our pilots is we're observing.
We have ideas.
Some of the amazing teachers
and principals and students,
we've been working with have ideas.
We're essentially trying them out,
and we're seeing what
works and what doesn't.
What you can expect from us over
the course of the next year,
is us sharing what we think
are the best practices,
or us encouraging some of these
awesome teachers and principals,
to share what are the best practices.
They've already had a
ton of really good ideas,
for building that
community in the classroom.
What we're going to do on our end, is
try to build as many technology tools,
that also facilitate it.
Right now kids are writing on the
wipe board what they need help with,
or what they can help.
Well, we could probably build a
little tool to facilitate that,
within the classroom.
It's all on the table though.
We're always exploring
and always open to ideas.
The third question.
"One of your most talked about ideas
concerns flipping the classroom.
"Can you describe how and why that works?"
This is interesting because
I gave a Ted Talk in April,
and I talk about flipping
the class room where,
early on in Khan Academy I had made these
videos and I got letters from teachers,
saying, "Hey look you already gave a
video on finding a limit of a function,
"or adding and subtracting
negative numbers."
So those teachers said, hey they don't
have to give that lecture anymore,
so they're having those students
watch those lectures at home.
Then they were freeing up
class time to do more problems,
essentially what used to be homework.
That is kind of a traditional pure flip.
That by itself, I think,
is a very powerful thing.
You're using class time,
once again, to interact.
Just even that flip, by itself, even
before we talk about any other technology,
some people say, "Well,
unmotivated students right now,
"aren't doing their homework.
What makes you think,
"that they're going to watch videos?"
A partial answer is,
well we have technology,
that the teachers can track
that and all the rest.
But the more important
answer is, they might not.
Although, I suspect they will
because it's easier to watch a video,
than to do a problem that
you don't know how to do.
That's most of the reason why I think
a lot of kids don't do their homework.
Because they start and they
get frustrated and they stop.
Even if you assume that the same
kid who didn't do homework before,
isn't going to watch a
video now, what I say is,
"Well, if you're going to skip out
on anything, it's better to skip out,
"on the lecture than to
skip out on the exercises."
What happens is with
the flipped classroom,
at least when you're in
the room with the teacher,
you're able to do exercises.
You're able to do it with
the help of your friends,
and whoever else is there.
The real way that you're learning things,
the exercises are what really
get you to the next level.
The opposite, where you're using class
time to passively listen to a lecture,
and then you don't do homework.
That's the worst of everything.
You're probably not paying attention to
the lecture so you're zoned out there.
And you're also not doing the exercises.
The ideal is obviously,
students watch the videos.
We think they're much more
likely to watch videos,
and everything we've observed
seems to verify that,
that students want to learn it's
just that traditional homework,
they often get frustrated because
they don't know how to do it,
and there's no one there to help them.
So you can flip it that way.
With all of that said we want to be clear,
that we're not just about
flipping the classroom anymore.
I kind of mentioned the word
halfway into my Ted Talk,
and I think the media and the
press love a very simple word,
like flip the classroom
and homework at school,
and schoolwork at home and
all of that type of thing.
We're not actually saying that
this is the 100 percent ideal.
What we're saying is, 100 percent
ideal is doing everything,
to allow every student to work at
their own pace, at their own time.
For every student to master concepts,
so that they don't have
gaps in their knowledge,
so they don't move on with
just C level of understanding,
or B level of understanding.
And to humanize the classroom
as much as possible.
The flip is the start to do this,
but we think you can go even further,
if you have self-paced
exercises and you have feedback,
and you have dashboards, and you
have dashboards for teachers.
I want to make it very clear.
This is something that the
media has grabbed on to.
That we kind of view as
a intermediary solution.
But we think the ideal solution,
and we're still exploring,
what that ideal solution is.
But we think that the right answer is,
don't just flip for the sake of flipping,
or just because the word
flip is a nice buzz word,
that people are excited about.
Do everything in your power to
make class time as interactive,
and as deep, and as
exploratory as possible.
And use technology in ways to empower
kids to work at their own pace,
at their own time, and
get as much data possible,
to teachers and parents, and
frankly to the students themselves.